[Musik]
mein name ist willkommen meine damen und
herren ihr seht es bereits im titel wir
machen heute mal wieder locker falls die
website regel nicht kennen sollte da
kann man video chatten
ich zeige euch nur ein ausschnitt von
einem alten orgel video von mir sein
kontrakt ist es doch irgendwie weg
bringt das machen wir heute allerdings
nicht normal einfach dass ich mit den
leuten lama et cetera pp da wird
natürlich auch im heutigen video darin
vorkommen allerdings werde ich wenn ich
auf die leute treffe denen einen dummen
witz vorlesen und auf die reaktion
warten hier gut was machst du so
das alles
warum leiden für mich an zu weinen nein
wie geht's dir bitte weinig war sein ich
glaube ich gar nicht ändern wenn leute
beim ich sitze da bist ja mega emotionen
ja immer zu emotional
möchtest du vielleicht ein foto machen
oder irgendwie sowas sehr gut ich habe
auch ein witz vorbereitet ich wollte
jeder person mit der ich heute im
videochat auf mängel wollte ich den witz
vorlesen
bist du bereit nun kommt ein dachdecker
in eine bar da sagt der wirt der geht
aufs haus
schau mal das problem ist ich hatte auch
mal locker t shirt so also den witz so
glaube ich nicht so kuppel ok und
dadurch ist ein t shirt dreckig geworden
ja ja das natürlich scheiße cup andere
fragen können sich danach ins biotop
holt jetzt ein bruderduell du ich habe
heute ich mache mich also omega also
merken dass das klappt mache so video
chatten mit ein paar zuschauern und ich
habe für jeden ein witz vorbereitet ein
vampir auf dem tandem wird von der
polizei angehalten sagt die polizei
haben sie etwas getrunken
der antwortet der vampir jahr zwei
radler
was wirklich komplett hey hey was geht
und was macht so ein riesen fan von dir
deine mama ja
[Musik]
deine mutter ins rieselfeld vor mir und
ja ich habe für die heutige folge habe
ich mir für jeden den ich treffe hier
bei oracle habe ich einen witz
vorbereitet wir richtig guten wird gehe
ich dass ich habe gestern bei weight
watchers angerufen aber es hat keiner
abgenommen
du hast nur aus mitleid als alles klar
bei euch hier hört euch an wieso
johlende welpen wollt ihr ein foto
machen oder so da fühlt wir gerade schon
die ganze frau aber mädels ich habe
heute für jeden gast ähnliche treffe bei
oracle habe ich eine mega krassen witz
vorbereitet ich erzähle den euch mal wie
heißt der vegetarische bruder von bruce
lee brokkoli
doch kann ich mich witzig also das ist
gar nicht mein merge hat doch das ist
wirklich gut
wie fandet also auf einer skala von eins
bis elf wie fandet ihr meinen witz dass
das kommt beste kompliment dass hier
bekommen habe das ist jule weil ich habe
seit 20 zu finden
thomas maar um jux aber im endeffekt
niemand ich hab dich hier oben gefällt
ich hab immer zugehört wenn du gesagt
hast und dann habe ich immer auch nur du
bist so ein opfer dass du nichts
besseres zu tun hast ich bin ziemlich
beschissen naja julia also für jeden
gilt ja das gleiche ich habe ein paar
witze vorbereitet die ich jedem kann was
ihr mit brokkoli foul treffen sich zwei
rosinen sagt die eine zu der anderen
warum hast du einen helm auf da sagt die
andere ich muss gleich in den stollen
lachen ja ok willst du einfach mal danke
ich mir doch seine fanpage sagen dass
ich dabei instagram vielleicht mal
vorbeischauen laser luca okay da würde
ich auch mal vorbeischauen
hey hey was geht alles super und wir
sind jetzt als die ich gesehen habe
nicht mehr so gerhard gesessen hat wir
haben morgen in der schule wert verharrt
morgen wieder schule ab die nicht schon
längst die dafür schule sachsen ach ja
er macht in ferien du ich habe für jeden
den ich heute treffe hier auf oracle
habe ich einen witz vorbereitet wie
viele liegestütze kann chuck norris
[Musik]
5 alle a cool cool es ist wirklich das
ist super cool aber dazu den er nicht so
lustig vater zweiten für dich okay
was ist süß und läuft durch die wüste
[Musik]
ein karamell
ja ja ja das hat der ist ja komm ich
habe noch einen dritten für dich ich
habe den leuten nach hause ja ich habe
ich hart kommt ein cowboy zum friseur
pony weg also dass du ich war auf ich
glaube ich sollte man youtube kanal
löschen
jetzt habe ich also gewarnt kein problem
sie jetzt der beste tag deines lebens
oder recht
ich bin fake dankeschön kein problem
hatte ich noch zwei leute gruß ja klar
natürlich begrüße ich carina und laura
schöne grüße hat carina und laura h ich
auch kein problem ich habe für jeden den
ich heute hier bei onkel treffer habe
ich einen mega mega krassen innovativen
witz vorbereitet soll ich deine
begeisterung hält sich in grenzen
du weißt ja die japanische krieger
heißen die hat man ja nie was also wenn
die haltigen darum kämpfen wie nennt man
einen unentschlossenen japanischen
krieger
erzählen nun ja die erneut fandest du
den witz auf einer skala von 13 bis 400
toastbrot hätte ich auch gesagt hallo
hallo wie geht's gut ist mein hund sehen
ja die schwester heißt baby oder ja aber
wo ich hier gerade schon bei schlechten
witzen bin du ich habe mir gedacht dass
ich jeder person die ich heute hier bin
treffe einen witz erzählen
okay okay ich schieß mal los wie nennt
man verärgerte gummibärchen harry bös
also meine liebe tina der witz für dich
ist wie nennt man ein trauriges kondomen
[Musik]
keine ahnung ich bin ganz ehrlich habe
mir das im zweiten moment gecheckt alter
aus welchem material bestehen straßen im
weltraum
inhalt her hallo was geht bei mir geht
auch alles hast du morgen wieder schule
kommt überhaupt auf deutschland oder
österreich oder so ich komme aus nrw aus
einer www wenn ich jetzt gerade oft
camera herausgefunden dass wir beide aus
dem gleichen scheiß ort kommen er geht
auf eine schule die zwei kilometer von
mir ist da wo meine eltern wohnen
an der stelle des heutigen wie jetzt
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
zuschauer also dass gerade war das war
ja mehr der zufall ich frage wo kommst
du her sagt zu meinen ort main beim
neuen heimatort beim mega krank er hat
mich auch schon mal getroffen wo du am
straßenrand stand ist mit dem mini das
ist glaube ich irgendwo irgendwie eine
panne oder sogar classic luca ist aber
auch komplett egal ich würde auf jeden
fall an dieser stelle jetzt das heutige
video beenden wenn euch dieser teil
oracle mit luca gefallen hat dann lasst
einen fetten daumen hoch unter diesem
video hier das schaffen wir 50.000 likes
wenn wir das schaffen kommen nächste
woche direkt ein zweiter teil oracle mit
euch und mir mit luca und jetzt wo neben
ein kanal noch keinen entscheid und das
auto ist jetzt dran
[Musik]